on le dit depuis ce matin depuis hier
soir en fait l'espoir renaît pour le
canadien de montréal on le sera à
montréal c'est imperceptible mais wapt
la nouvelle série qui était en marge
rejoint avec plaisir mon camarade dany
dubé qui devant le madison square garden
à new york
dany en deux mots c'est vraiment une
nouvelle série qui commence absolument
patrice à l'environnement à la sq et en
corse qui a réussi à faire c'est
d'inspirer ses coéquipiers de redonner
confiance à cette équipe qui avait perdu
son joueur-vedette carey price on sait
on vraiment là on a un nouvel une
nouvelle dynamique que je pense que le
jeune gardien même un petit peu dans la
tête des joueurs des rangers
mais parlez moi de ton gosse qui dany
d'abord rappeler aux gens qui suivent
pas ça comme vous d'où vient-il
et qu'est-ce qui comment ce fait-il que
michel terrains du site et que c'était
lui qui devait pas être là et plutôt
buddha bar ski c'est un jeune gardien
qui a eu du succès à tous les niveaux
il a été repêché par le lightning de
tampa bay alors ça c'est important de le
savoir
il a joué dans l'organisation du
lightning il a gagné la coupe calder
pour l'entraîneur john cooper qui aimait
tant l'entraîneur chef du lightning de
tampa bay il a gagné également la
médaille d'or au championnat du monde
junior il était le gardien numéro 1 il a
été choisi le meilleur gardien du
tournoi ce qui est pour rien avance
toujours comme ça c'est le gardien
canadien qui gagne est le meilleur
gardien
mais depuis plusieurs années on voit
d'erreurs on voit des des gardiens de la
république tchèque on voit même des
suédois des finlandais gagner ce trophée
très prestigieux l'huile a gagné
également
il a été aussi il est titulaire de la
coupe memorial oms qui a gagné à tous
les niveaux l'entraîneur le savaient ils
admettent alité de gardien de but numéro
un et c'est la raison pour laquelle
entraîneur a baissé de jeter son dévolu
carrément sur lui plutôt que sur good
eye qui était le gardien de but de
réserve car mes beaux d'abord il va
pleurer le reste de l'été quoi y est
finie pourquoi je sais pas s'ils vont
pleurer je les buts à la dans
l'ascenseur y avait un beau sourire mais
c'est sûr que pour lui dans le cas de
bouddha et c'est un gardien de but de
réserve et je pense que là ce qu'on
comprend tous ces grands pas c'est déjà
cette année quand price était blessé et
il a participé à sept matchs et n'a que
deux victoires
ensuite il a également travaillé l'an
passé a durant les séries contre ottawa
alors que price était blessé mon match
numéro 5 il a dit il a accordé six buts
c'était une défaite cuisante du canada
du canadien c'est ça alors je pense
qu'on savait ce qu'on pouvait avoir de
bouddha et c'était nécessairement où
évidemment pas suffisant pour permettre
au canadien de montréal d'être dans le
coup d'années on a beaucoup parlé cette
année avec vous marie-josée également de
la violence et tout ça les peines qui
ont été donnés aujourd'hui deux matches
à brandon prost pour son coup de coude
et corsino des rangers et 10 matchs
parce qu'il est sensible
il s'en est pris à un arbitre c'est bien
un à bédouès et ça c'est absolument
aller dans quelques heures si lola s'est
bousculé l'arbitré automatiquement ça je
pense qu'il faut sévir il faut être très
intransigeant ce qu'on a été du côté de
la ligue et honnêtement
prost un joueur que j'apprécie beaucoup
cinq courageux pour le canadien de
montréal mais c'était je pense qu' il
fallait absolument sévir sur ce coup
c'est un coup alors que le joueur était
vulnérable apace avait été fait depuis
déjà plus d'une seconde nina des
processions de la rondelle n'a pas vu
l'adversaire arrivés vers lui en
l'occurrence prost je pense que c'est
normal de sévir mais vous savez quoi
ça va pas désavantager le canadien parce
que si c'est bon nival qui prend sa
place sur le quatrième trio ni vent ni
beaucoup plus de vitesse que prost en
amener alors je pense pas que les
canadiens aux changes est pénalisé très
bien en 30 secondes dani vous y croyez
vous à une remontée réel tout est
possible tout est possible parce que le
canadien doit jouer ce genre de match
c'est à dire un match à beaupont étages
très serré ici vous savez la foulée elle
peut être très très exigeante et à aimer
ce qui est de même avec avec les siens à
l'occasion et rappelons-nous 48 ans à
new york pour les rangers c'est pas une
bonne nouvelle on va leur parler pendant
deux jours de cette défaite je pense que
ça va ça ne fera qu'envenimer la
situation les rend plus nerveux le début
le début de match pour les deux équipes
ce sera un impératif la bonne soirée à
new york d'année ans je te salue mais à
la prochaine on va suivre ça dimanche
les zèbres salut